Troy you ten minutes I just gotta put on
that clothes you could have like the
body of a man now Hideki not be weird
okay you close my door yeah you close
the door yeah going off to find your
college let's make this a special we're
fully booked tonight how about that one
it's not available Oh looks like it's
available yeah it's not at night my mind
drifted back to college so many friends
have become successful
Craig Fisher worked for the White House
Jason Hatfield at his own hedge fund
really worst first sold his tech company
is 40 what do I have I work for a
non-profit ain't nothing to show for it
somebody asked about you you know
whatever helps you present all right I
love you
these are competitive schools Troy just
try not to put too much pressure on
yourself
I failed so thanks again to pretty much
everywhere I apply kids going to Harvard
don't jinx me did my son is a very
talented musician also composes his own
music so wonderful I'm pretty sure
Harvard is gonna be in the running you
think Harvard's got a chance suddenly my
thoughts darkened Troy could easily end
up struggling like me this is Harvard
even geniuses get rejected we need to do
everything we can yeah I'm about to go
have my interview do you really need to
be jumping all over me right now you're
nuts
I sound jaded I started out as
idealistic as any of your friends over
there you're 50 years old and you still
think that the world was made for you
I'm 47 sometimes I worry that people
think of me as a failure oh that's right
you have your little thing oh that is a
cool thing that you do that is good
stuff dear friends I'm like dicks
everybody's just thing about themselves
the only person that's thinking about
you is me
doesn't crazy how who made this kid is
this brilliant amazing person proud of
you
[Applause]
daddy having some kind of nervous
breakdown or something
you